people of youtube ladies and gentlemen
of the internet
we are craig and aaron we are loud and
extreme today
we are going to watch invincible episode
five
it's called that actually hurt just like
how your earbuds did from listening to
our voices at the beginning here
now on our last video episode 4 i did
see a few comments of people
saying because we had some criticisms
quite a
few comments of people being like we're
not ready for episode 5 and
don't worry your criticisms will be
addressed in episode five
sounds like ominous hell yeah i hope
you're the same people hit the dislike
button so early on in that video
speaking of which hit that like button
if you enjoyed our reaction
subscribe click that notification bell
to get notified when our next one is up
as always
full length watch along where you sync
up with the time code watch along with
us is over at our patreon page and over
there we cover a crap ton of other shows
as well and i want to say a sincere
thank you to everyone who's followed us
sincerely uh your support
overwhelming means a lot and uh do not
take it for granted
at all unlike john he takes it for
granted
terrible human being speaking of which
prothom jindal thank you for editing
these reaction highlights for us so
let's get into it
no john's all right john's great i love
john we're on camera we gotta say nice
things
it looks bad if we tell them the truth
about jaw
i can't speak for greg but i love john
[Music]
oh he used to smoke cigarettes did you
years ago yeah
spring back flashbacks yeah oh but no
the weapons really are
luke cage i think that's the rock guy
from the last one that
who mark b oh yes yes yes yes yes
do it yeah yeah
hmm
now this guy's invincible okay mark you
got some competition
oh
[Laughter]
this guy's back
damn oh that's superhero abuse right
there
no
it's not like captain america with a
shield right you know
gab would never do something there's no
way you're going to be mad at me
because i brought you japanese
cheesecake
spiderman
you're a menace
what did we ever do to you
sweat pores race on third and parkland
oh
they'll put you up for a few weeks okay
that's
nice ish for what you just did to them
take everything i got photo the family
if his whole body's covered in rocks you
think his
toes are too yeah okay cool
that was my biggest concern his penis
now why would you say his people
it would be worth the wait to see me on
my best behavior
on thursday if you value everything you
hold dear
grayson
bro some stuff going on right now
black mask
that's a strange mask that's a long soul
patch bro
oh how neat oh yeah potato
oh oh how neat i'm done see titan your
problem is
you're too useful this is what you do
no this is a voice just get electronic
out of nowhere
what are you doing i know where your
family lives
[Laughter]
impressive [ __ ] like that is exactly why
i'm never
letting you go
[Laughter]
i brought you food from friends your
mom's a great cook
you should have told that yourself
during dinner two hours ago
i tried to text you am i important to
you mark of course
well it really doesn't feel like it half
the time we make plans
you're late or you cancel or you just
don't show and your excuses suck
remember that thing about consequences
you're talking about
i have these family responsibilities
it's hard
making it all fit then make that choice
but then this
i'm not doing this anymore
dude
come on man property damage so this
whole reaction is us just going
wow we're really uh we're wrong we're
wrong we said we went to the seasons
until the next episode of doing
everything yeah i'm pretty full from all
these words that i'm eating
[Laughter]
and i really like this titan character a
lot yeah he's awesome
titan spin-off i got you a gift because
i love you
because we're family did somebody ask
for butterscotch ripple
why did they make it a scary thing it's
called a mislead it's a classic writing
trick
come on here but nothing about that
seemed
i know it wasn't very good it wasn't a
good one
a superhero
what's his name him he calls himself
[Applause]
more blood splatter yeah buddy yeah
buddy make it bloody what is that
building
oh it's a book okay okay
that's like a necronomicon what'd you
call me
[Music]
according to the galaxy
hey i need my costume back i don't care
how torn up it is
it's classified and i want it back oh i
love where this show is shaping up he's
so
smartly waiting and conceived
you're sending the message titan you
missed a few letters
paint costs money you got a long-ass
name
[Laughter]
you're out for revenge fine let's do
this
i called you here because i need your
help so aren't you a hero
helping people and taking down bad guys
yeah
so help me take down my boss who's your
boss
machine head that's not a real name of
course you haven't heard of
you're a rich kid from the suburbs what
no i'm
i'm middle middle class let me show you
what you don't see from up there
[Laughter]
all these videos doing is sipping a
straw to mcclure manly
it's some [ __ ] uses it to ferry
drugs to stash houses all over the city
oh that's clever criminals take some
tips
eat your pen and paper i have to fix it
then burns them for insurance
money you help me take down machine head
you help real people with real lives
why'd you borrow money from machine head
anyway
this dude feels like luke cage mixed
with sandman
do you think i should help this titan
guy out you'd be making a huge mistake
you're the worst dude this is beneath
you put your alien dick away
mark hey you slow down tiger you're
still on my tiger
told she had mj vibes do not stand me up
on this
okay it won't only be me counting on you
this time 7 p.m
oh man i gotta run i told my mom myself
you want to come tonight we could use
the help i wish i could but
too busy saving the world not anymore
actually
no excuse then does she know yeah does
she have a public identity i don't know
she doesn't wear a mask can't the
teleporter guy just pull machine head
out once we get close
he's got a girl he sees a couple of
times a week i paid her extra to keep
him there all evening
what oh
prostitution i really love this episode
this is a great one
that's so much heart and so personal
this is the character episode
immediately it's going to be like i'm
the original
thank you for waking me clone
[Laughter]
oh is he transferring his brain matter
welcome to the world of the living oh
they want them to never know i'm the
original
i'll never understand why you do that oh
letting himself be revealed i need your
expertise in tissue growth
and dna replication hmm
what's you up to robot if you have a sec
could you pick up a few things for
dinner
super sized it's still not long enough
to delay oh
but you would know that's clever i love
this
i love this this is this is a really
great one
yeah oh she's snooping
she's snooping what am i doing
oh it's the bloody one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh god oh god she knows
i'm nervous she doesn't know exactly she
doesn't know everything yet
what she has
dude get up we're taking you in
do you not hear them bro oh hello
invincible
i knew they were coming rock you said
you took care of him i know what i said
oh [ __ ] ah
oh crap
he's going to be late to amber ah damn
it
that's honestly what's on my mind
like make it work man
can you call for backup man
oh damn dad's just waiting
it's like look at you messing up son
oh my god damn
oh no
omni man come please
oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
oh you got your dad's temper bro ah
did you murder that man oh my god you're
[ __ ] crazy
i thought he who's got a murderer oh my
god i thought we're about to see some
some tragedy some devastation
wait okay
oh damn
that's an ass whooping right there
oh damn guardians anonymous call
[Music]
this is great you're going to see them
be badass
oh this is great
oh oh man
robot no uh oh
oh dude for explode you be getting your
ass kicked a lot lately
yes you do yes you do this way you have
to work as a team
yep we're about to try to tell you
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
oh no oh what
what holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the holy [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god no no black's absent
oh my god oh god
that was rough
omni man do something please
oh my god what is happening here
oh my god we're destroying them
no whoa
what are you oh god oh
no no you killed monster girl
no no no no
oh my god you guys just messed up
indeed big time oh she's
oh is there a team now i guess that's
what
they had to happen
to just kill off like my god
two or three people right in one swoop
oh my god
wow
oh
oh man this battle is beneath oh man
we're killing insects no
no no this was an unexpected possibility
oh he
really cared for her oh man
how are you still alive man sorry kid
didn't mean forth in this way
your story i gotta take care of mine oh
what what the hell are you kidding man
i loved you damn i love you dude
yeah it's gotta be like that just broke
my heart man
sorry bro dude oh man we gonna lose him
it's a possibility sir no we need him do
whatever it takes
get a sample to the lab oh god what is
it gonna take
get a sample to the lab that life could
be the thing that
oh that cure is the
the blobby thing no i'm getting at all
i'll tell you later
oh yeah adam probably wouldn't happen if
you were there what's wrong
was that mark
i know it's hard to love someone when
they don't seem to love you back but
mark loves
he'd you here if he could oh man
i gotta hand it to you boss but whatever
you told that kid to get him on your
side
oh no
he's the boss oh
oh he was just a robot the guy oh
oh wait i think he just made himself
the kingpin he just made himself yeah
yeah
damn wow oh
dude you broke my heart man man you guys
you got us on your side
oh wow dude
um now i'm saying the blood sample that
they've been trying to find for like dna
uh because they can't i don't think
they're really a dna sign with vomiting
now oh that's right
were they he was hospitalized i don't
know i'm thinking we've tried everything
drugs viruses bacteria prions
even nanobots and radioactives
filtramite cells
don't give a damn oh they just won't die
wow i got a feeling blood's still the
answer
wow oh so they trying to figure out how
to kill him
through his blood okay oh
damn wow god
i mean we know mark's gonna be okay but
jesus dewey
i mean he's he's a title character i'm
sure
so what that'd be so who was rehearsal
wait he was in this it just said it
right there oh i'm sure he's i think
he's probably the kingpin guy
titan yeah he's probably titan you know
someone on patreon said if i scroll over
it would show you the crass credits and
that ain't happening right now
um you would liar patreon
man he was a fibber
i'll figure out later man that was a
phenomenal episode that was great
that was a that was it was it right here
marshall the nicole byer
i don't know who chris diamanta is i
think he's rex
chris he's no no that's that's uh man
what was his name chris mann's nah i
forget his name
yeah yeah it's that no it's not
die dimension top bolo who's nicole
buyer play
i don't even know who that is nicole
byer from nailed
it the netflix show
wait what does she nailed it i mean
she's actually like a really edgy
comedian when she has the netflix show
nailed it is that the name of her show
yeah
the baking show it's a great show oh i
think i've seen every episode
who plays rex splode
explode jason manzoukis yeah that's
different
who the who are we talking about chris
manikuka lux is
trying to remember off the name here and
a current cuddling
uh it's not there's nothing it doesn't
exist all right all right
hot diggity damn damn damn you know
once in a while remember to take notes
yeah yeah a lot happened
that's that's definitely the best one i
think uh out of any of the ones you've
seen
i think it rivals the pilot the pilot
was pretty great i was way more emotion
i was more emotional i mean the pilot's
like the introduction and definitely has
the shock value of the ending for me
like this is what really puts me on edge
is like the emotional
involvement of stuff yeah that character
and the character build up the character
intermingling dramas like when mark is
getting really mad he's like i'll kill
all your whatever he says yeah
yeah i'm like oh my god don't be your
dad that's where my mind starts going
that's what i mean by the emotional
investment like that
the violent shock factor of the pilot
yeah those i mean i don't think you can
top the shock unless you've read the
comics but for people who haven't read
the comics like that's such a surprising
moment
whereas um here it's like maybe this
isn't as violently shocking however it's
the context of we know what his dad is
like he has a chance of being good
and so for me for him to go there i'm
like oh my god don't become
murderous like your father maybe that's
what it'll take to survive right now but
don't
but don't become that man you're going
to be late for amber man like that kind
of stuff puts me on edge yeah yeah
we have yet to see him actually kill
anybody huh yeah maybe you know
superheroes
i feel like with batman like it's about
mark it's like crossing that line
yeah like actually murdering the freak
out yeah maybe he's accidentally killed
someone but yeah
he hasn't like cold blooded murdered
like i hate you i'm going to murder you
or something yeah he hasn't done
anything like that i'm in the same boat
with you about the the character stuff
that's the reason why spider-man is
probably my favorite superhero
and seeing the things that mark has to
deal with
like kind of similar to peter parker but
the home life and the origin of
him as a hero and the context of what he
does as a hero is completely different
which makes that even more interesting
like you the amber stuff really
uh speaks out to me the motif of time
was really important in this episode
well yeah they said three months had
passed too that makes sense because i
did have a moment of
you guys seem awfully close
until you do it like three weeks
how is mark this good of a superhero by
now and then when they said that three
months i was like okay
that clears up a lot in my head yeah so
having having that uh time like like you
said does
play a factor here literally all the
criticisms that we were having was funny
like
i didn't say any of those criticisms
like really clearly
until last episode yeah which was
um about like i wish some of the teen
life
felt more palpable like you got to see
both you got to see like what's it
what's the toll it takes on their
personal life and and you get that with
mark the miscalculations and his
decision-making
because he's still an amateur at this
and that's what i mean it's so it's so
richly
nuanced it's so it's such a great
because you're like
man on me man you're being a dick let
him let him help out titan
these people need your help right he's
like he's using you
yeah yeah you don't realize it but you
know
i i love that and then come to find out
he was right
there was right man
that's that's wild the show the show was
so layered in the fact that
i think it walks this interesting line
between being something
more real like the boys and having
something more um more heartfelt like a
spider-man show
but also you said kind of harley quinn
reminded you of yeah it's also got like
kick-ass vibes yeah kick-ass is totally
yeah totally one of them
seeing those things all come into tandem
is really cool
really interesting but the fact that it
walks that line of
being like a genuine superhero show
while also
in a non-cynical way kind of tapping
into the realistic things what happened
in a world of superheroes like
you trying to help this underdog guy
which turns out to [ __ ] you over
because that's how the world is
sometimes it does in such a
cleverly woven way because you really
get on titus aside and i'm like
man it really breaks your heart to see
that come to fruition but you also kind
of get it why he goes that way
because like you gotta look out for your
family but i don't know man i think that
coming together it's funny you know like
we were comparing him to luke cage
yeah and if you remember how season two
of luke cage ended
here comes the the body because the boss
said harlow right yeah
and and to think back here what is the
guy
machine head is that his name yeah
machine that's the part of this
show okay really quick on on the naming
of the characters that's the part of
this world
of why i thought we were entering like
there's
what i would say is none of none of this
is a spoof but there's a satire quality
to it yeah you know and that that comes
through a lot in the naming of the
characters
at the same time they still let their
characters be three-dimensional they're
not
just like hey you remind me of this
other comic character they're
their own thing at the end of the day
even down to the gods or the these like
villainous people they pull from other
portals so like with names like machine
head that
to me sounds like a satire name but it's
still its own character it's still a
cleverly rich character i love the whole
ingredient of
how he's able to uh foresee a bunch of
probabilities
kind of like my hero academia that one
character uh night eye
yeah yeah yeah yeah kind of like night
eye except you know much
cockier version what we were talking
about before right went on this little
tangent about
oh about but it yeah when they were
together uh
working as a unit to me i was getting
the vibes of
man people in concert like you were
ready for this episode and i'm like all
right they'll deliver on some stuff
this is like the best one when they were
working together uh
invincible and uh titan oh this is kind
of like the dynamic i was wanting of
iron fist and luke cage in the netflix
marvel show
yeah like this is this is the chemistry
i was sort of hoping for
it still had an important tale to tell
even though he had a learning lesson
like it's such a
interesting thread they had because i
loved how it was it's not about
saving millions of people sometimes
sometimes it's about helping the people
on the ground level
like the actual civilians that one the
friendly neighborhood
save one
[Laughter]
you'll know i usually just push people
that's right i'm gonna quote the chance
to sleep
that's my jam i totally
feel what you mean about them having the
the kind of vibe of
iron fist and loot cave like how you're
saying has that sort of similar thing of
trying to
homage or like has like a spoofish
quality about it but it does it in its
own way like
it seems like it's going that way but
just slightly tilted you know yeah and
that tilt
is just enough for it to be unique in
its own right especially with all the
components coming together
making this unique story it's like wow i
love the way that the
this is unfolding i think it's
interesting from a character or from a
story standpoint to have titan become
kind of the kingpin character but i also
think it's it makes me worried for mark
as a character for trusting people again
exactly
and what kind of hero that's going to
mold him inform him to be because you're
getting these ideals of how to be a
virtuous hero from his mom but you're
also seeing the
the kind of negative side of what that's
like from his dad and
those two things coming to a head
especially within this episode
it's it makes me both intrigued and
worried for the future of
mark grayson well it makes me wonder
about the dad because about nolan so i'm
like wait
is did nolan have it's to the point now
where i'm wondering did nolan have good
intentions of what he did
like vicious murder that he did at the
pilot was there some type of
good intention that he had because he
was essentially
right about everything he was saying in
his own weird
sociopathic detached way maybe well he
was telling
well he was telling mark or telling
debbie mark is just a kid
and he thinks he knows everything and
what about being a hero already
and in this episode it starts off where
he is just
he's he's cocky about everything he
thinks he can easily just get
forgiveness from amber he quits his
job like like it's no big deal he's you
know it's like he wants to be
attending for school but it's like i
don't really care to go to college you
know you are dealing with the the
struggle of the things he cares about in
his personal life
and being a superhero however he does
have he he is developing an ego even
when he's interacting with titan for the
first time on the roof
yeah he's like i'll take you you know
his whole persona his ego was like his
downfall in this
because it let him blind him through so
much of his decision making
and yeah we're on his side so we're
blinded along the way in the journey you
know
having us have these first three four
episodes
of him being a cocky character to now
see the consequences of that
makes it hit harder as well yeah and it
means more because we
because you saw us in the last episode
like like oh
nothing's happened in his life like
everybody loves him it's so good
he keeps getting whipped that's not the
case gonna bite him in the ass even
harder once he heals
and seeing like the personal uh
struggles that these characters go
through right down to eve with her
family
like that was the moment where i was
really starting to feel
right there was when i realized i'm in
love with this episode was because they
did
more than just mark like getting that
example of eve to having to be a girl in
high school but then having these
parents where she
essentially has the powers of someone
like a scarlet witch watching how her
dad treats her
and it feels like she still needs to be
dependent on a guy her dad
thinks she still needs to be dependent
on a guy to look out for her even though
she's gone he's wild gracious
i think she's good i think she'll be
fine having that and then you got
the new guardians that you have to deal
with it's so weird to watch how these
threads all kept weaving because
they like the guardians they're they're
cocky at the beginning
yeah they're they're having beers when
they shouldn't and then by the end
they lose but in the process of them
losing they finally learn
yeah come in and charge this together
and i was like yeah this is all working
for me i never felt like it teased
monster girl or um what's what's his
name black samson yeah black samson's
death yeah
or deaths or injuries because they
treated them like
no these are this is a team that's going
to be going forward kind of similar out
of the pilot treated the
original guardians of the globe the
beautiful thing about the show is you
never know what's going to happen
and i think because of that and the deep
character development and growth and
process we're seeing go along
it makes it that much richer you know
absolutely a thousand percent
and on top of that too you know i gotta
say the action is
like i know we're mainly talking about
the character like a bunch of snobs
i think the action is also a big part of
what lends itself to it being its own
thing it doesn't just remind me of
other superhero stuff the creativity
they have with the choreography of
titan's first scene when he's messing up
that whole gang and the way the bullets
will ricochet
off of him landing to other people some
of the absorption moments that he has
the constant switching of appearing uh
reappearing and appearing and then the
whole fight scene at the end that big
finale fight all
that was so well choreographed all their
powers were really on display
and like the new guardians yeah they had
some action scenes before but this was
the moment where they had a chance to
really be in an intense situation
where they had an opportunity to to at
least represent themselves
in the heroic light so their action
scenes held more weight this time as
opposed to before where i don't
i don't i didn't really remember what
they did before no like was like episode
two or three i don't know which one in
this one i'm like oh look at them all
going at it and then the different
display especially with the girl who
shrinks like the ant-man ability
yeah the way they play with the scope of
her powers or sometimes it's like
you have to pay attention to watch or
shrink yeah it's very cleverly done
and especially the the scene that you
pointed out when we were watching it
like when um
when black sampson was talking about
they're not working as a team and like
she kind of like shrunk a little bit
kind of oh it's so subtle yeah yeah i'm
talking about her mental state i'm like
wow it's
just the way they they utilize these
people's powers is very
very clever and debbie is now finding
out
yeah she's she's uncovering the secret
she's on she's pulling those threads
and it makes me really scared for what's
gonna happen when when it's all
unraveled it's so easy to make
the the the lover to the
the the non-powered spouse
boring it's so easy to make that
character dull just have her be
essentially she could have just
ended up like an ant-may you know yeah
where emmy's great
a lot of times i just kind of associate
her with like she's she's super
supportive or really hot like marissa
told me you know it's
one of the two she's a super old lady
now she's put out a conflict you know
she has to look out for a kid she
suspects her husband it's hard to sneak
around her husband like that was such a
great ticket a literal ticking time
clock
to how she has 20 minutes to investigate
her own home to see if there's anything
she could find on her husband
and then how that's putting a toll on
her like am i really doubting him and
then finding some evidence it's making
everything
very personal for everyone where i i
feel like
you got the combination of struggle and
love on on almost every corner for these
characters
of how do i dealing with choices and
dealing with the consequences of those
choices and
even with amber i love the ending note
that it had with her and eve amber
knowing something's really wrong and up
amber knows there's something
that's not being told to her that is
serious right she feels left in the dark
she's left in the dark at the same time
when eve was looking at her
and saying he loves you there's some
stuff that's going on and that look that
they
at least painted her with on the show
this horror
on her face and she is so clueless as to
what that really means
it's just this is damn good television
this is damn good television right here
it's like really good this is really
good damn good
written damn good paced damn good
animated
just all of it damn good voice active
voice acting really sells it in addition
to like the animation style but
yeah i that that moment you're talking
about you really
feel the peril uh and the the realness
of what she was saying because like yeah
mark he loves you but something's also
not okay
and i look forward to finding out what
that is yeah they make this stuff that's
more
smaller level feel very gripping i think
that's great
like yeah mark get to that gotta be with
the hamburger yeah
yeah you gotta go help out you know
debbie's investigating [ __ ] you know
and all that all that stuff they make it
feel tense
it's there's so much tension i think
that was the thing is like this is a
i think from beginning to end there was
a sense of intensity
kind of throughout and it just seemed to
keep ramping up even
more escalating the stakes because yeah
you could feel that there was um
what's that game jenga where you keep
building the blocks on it and then it's
like you just know it's gonna fall over
yeah yeah yeah that's kind of what i
felt like they were doing here there's
like a game of jenga happening
where it's all building building okay
you're kind of keeping it together
and then it all just collapses at the
end and i'm like this is only the fifth
episode i can only imagine
i can only imagine what the next going
to be then
if this is the fifth one the stakes are
are raising you know our hero is about
to be in the hospital
you know having girlfriend troubles is
the wife's about to find out they're
getting closer and closer each day to
finding out the the truth of
what happened and like the day the
guardians died yeah the government omni
man
let like no mark saw his dad
in the air yeah it's it's kind of weird
how it seemed to have a
you know batman v superman when uh
superman is
like it's like a symbolic heroic
shh like zack snyder beautiful shot
whereas where the
person's on the roof the families on the
rooftop and then superman's like
being silhouetted by the sun oh talking
about like the godly shot
yeah yeah we're looking and then one
part of your brain's like why is he just
hovering
[Laughter]
you can save them damn it's beautiful
and that shot is what it reminded me of
yeah when
he's looking above him is like why
aren't you saving me yeah it's not
one for one but like they're definitely
you definitely get hints of
of like homelander in there like not
like the
the extremeness of like being like on
the verge of snapping his lack of
empathy like he
he cares but like in a weird detached
kind of way you know for humanity but
we've been known that
we don't know what his real deal is
that's what i find so great about omni
mans like we don't
unless you're in the comics we don't
know what the real deal is
yeah also the thing that they've
mentioned it twice because like how he's
been
changing ever since the whole mark thing
has happened it makes me wonder
how was debbie nolan's relationship
prior to marketing powers
was he always this kind of detached
towards humanity and like oh it'll be
fine
or is this now that he knows he's not
the only vulture might on earth
i think uh now from what they talked
about they've said that he
it seems like he's just been a lot
colder and quick tempered since
marcus since mark has uh yeah discovered
his powers
okay i mean it makes sense but i don't
know i wouldn't be mad if
if for some reason we got a a nolan
uh debbie prequel well they also talk
about too
how nolan was a certain type of
personality and then when he met debbie
a lot of that started to change
he started to adapt different points of
views
and it seems like he's kind of going
back to who he was
prior but so we don't know yeah yeah and
that's what i love about it is even
though the first
episode paints it uh he's the villain
now i'm like oh damn there's a lot of
a lot of other people you gotta worry
about that we need omniman to take care
of before we take care of auntie man
yeah
that lion guy who we saw he reminded me
of someone from dc i can't put my finger
on it somewhere in like
the cosmic side of dc kind of gave me
hints of i wonder if that's someone that
mark is gonna take down later in his
career
or if omni man's gonna take that dude
out maybe i feel like omni mac could
just like kind of do his own thing take
him out without saying anything that is
true yeah yeah we'll see stealthy style
well we'll see let's see guys
damn good television right here damn
good tv guys haven't done so already
subscribe
check us on patreon hit that like button
follow aaron on instagram
i have not encouraged any of you guys to
get in any of these videos
and now i am for the few who stay
towards the end last but not least
who's the unlucky son of a [ __ ] today
robert
gunderson so robert gunderson i started
getting on patreon so i had to like
make up some like silly patron of the
day shout out for him
then i got some pretty good goodies for
him for a follow-up shout out
oh and then i then i applied that and
then he
and then i i haven't heard from him in
like a couple months
so i don't know what to say for you now
robert now here i
am speechless aaron what do you want to
tell robert
robert well good sir i mean i don't know
you i like your last name you seem like
a
nice guy except when you ghost my friend
here you got all you got all danny
phantom on him you're gone ghost i don't
know what that's about
but you know we thank you for being a
patron your love and support is
definitely appreciated
uh you're a star in your own right uh
hit this hit this man back you know
it make it makes him sad with the
camera's off and the
the the lights are turned off and the
the crew's gone and the crowd starts
going away and the crowd starts going
wild
it really it did uh it it affects
it affects the home affects the life you
know
um he was he was so mad that you didn't
respond again in this cast bro
so just watch out for yourself he's
coming for you
he's coming for you wow if i ever get
caught doing anything wrong i'm never
gonna ask you to lie for me
like a weird spiral i'm gonna be tired